so let's see where we left off we were
studying the balance sheet of this Bank
eh I think that's what I called it and
we said okay on the asset side had some
government bonds had some triple-a
corporate bonds some commercial
mortgages and then this is the thing
that I really wanted to highlight is
that you all it also had four billion
dollars of residential collateralized
debt obligations and I explained a
little bit about what those are and I
have several videos where I explain that
in more detail and how they probably led
or most definitely led to the housing
bubble and then we have a little bit of
cash on top of that on the liability
side the bank just owns a lot of money
to people if this was were a commercial
bank kind of you know your bank of
Americas or your Chase's of the world
then one of the liabilities here would
have also been the deposits of the
people who kept keep their money at the
bank but we're not going to assume that
this could be just kind of any bank
actually this could this could be any
type of financial institution frankly it
doesn't have to be a bank this could be
the balance sheet of a of a hedge fund
or a private equity firm or pretty much
any type of financial institution but
anyway back to where we were in the
example we said then we learned it in
the first video and we learned it in the
balance sheet video that if you take
your assets and you subtract out your
liability so you take what you have you
subtract out what you owe you're left
with what you're really worth and that's
called your equity and if you're a
publicly traded company actual you don't
even have to be publicly traded but if
you're a corporation that's called your
shareholders equity and what does that
mean well that means the people who own
a stake in the company or the
shareholders they share this piece and
just to make hit the point home I think
this is an important one because I feel
like people kind of talk past this
there's two notions
there's your book value of equity and
that's the value of the equity that
comes out of your balance sheet so if
you assume that everything all of these
numbers are accurate and we're going to
think a lot about what it means to have
an accurate number here and you assume
that all of these numbers are accurate
then the number that pops out on the
equity side that is the book value of
your equity and just in this example I
said well let's say that Bank a is a
public company it has five hundred
million shares and so that means that if
you take us three billion dollars of
equity divided by five hundred million
shares that means that there is six
hours of book equity per share so that
means if these if all of these numbers
are correct then the stock of that
company is worth $6 per share
exactly exactly $6 per share I know
you're saying wait wait Sal doesn't make
sense we all know that the stock market
is a wild ride especially banking stocks
they swing left and right and and yeah
up and down and you know how can you
tell me that you know just by looking at
a balance sheet you can give an exact
amount for what its its equity value is
and that is an important distinction so
let me let me scroll down a little bit
maybe I'll erase this actually let me
let me clear this X I think it's a
distraction you might just want to watch
the video on mortgage-backed securities
and collateralized debt obligations if
you need a refresher there so what what
does it mean when a when you know I'm
telling you right now that a you know
you can look at a company's balance
sheet and if you believe what they say
you can actually calculate a book value
per share so so why do stock wide of
stocks fluctuate wildly left and right
well it's interesting it actually tells
you a lot about what the market thinks
about a company's balance sheet so I
mean let me let me fill this in this was
26 billion of assets and then I had what
23 billion of liabilities 23 billion and
then we get that is how we got equity of
3 billion and book equity per share or
the or the book value per share of $6
now let's say we you know we go on to
Yahoo Finance and we type in the ticker
symbol for this Bank
you know Bank a whatever we want to call
it and let's say that its market price
is I don't know it is $12 per share $12
per share so what is happening here the
the book value is $6 but the market is
saying no no we are willing to pay $12
per share for one of those shares and
just make a point here when you look up
a share price in the stock market or
even better when you buy a stock on the
stock market that money is not going to
the company the company initially raises
money by selling shares and that's often
done with an initial public offering
they will sell some shares directly to
the market and that money goes directly
to the company or they might do it in an
offering and
we'll talk more about that later but 99%
of the time when you buy a share it is
not going to the company it is going to
the previous person who held that share
that's why it's called a secondary
market it's not going to the company so
it's just a bunch of people trading the
share price and the only reason why that
share price really fundamentally matters
to the company is with the company were
to raise money at a future date so if
let's say the share price today is $12
let's say I bought a share for $12 a
share today that means I bought it from
maybe I bought it from you I didn't buy
it from the company but that at least
tells the company that if it were to go
to if it needed money if it needed to
raise money it could sell sell shares
probably it's something close to $12 a
share
it also tells someone who wanted to buy
out the whole company so if they wanted
to take over the company
that maybe if they offered some type of
a premium to $12 a share they could buy
out all of the stock well that's that's
not the topic for this and actually the
more I think about it I really should do
videos on all of these concepts but
anyway so the market is is is giving a
$12 per share value what does that mean
who the person who's paying $12 a share
is assuming that this is understated the
book value is understated and so if the
book value is understated that means
that either the assets are understated
or the liabilities are overstated most
times the liabilities are are pretty
easy to get a handle on sometimes
pension liabilities and or some type of
litigation liabilities that's hard to
get a grasp on but most time you can
look at a balance sheet oh you say okay
this is the money they owe that's not
too hard to value what is often very
interesting to value are the assets on a
balance sheet so if if you know with
this balance sheet you would say $6 per
share but the markets willing to say 12
they say you know what the company
either these assets are somehow being
undervalued or the company might have
some assets that somehow are not
captured on the balance sheet right so
maybe they're intangible assets or
there's some type of earning power that
in some way is not capture captured here
I think when I originally did the videos
on balance sheet I actually talked about
you know you can't you can't you can't
quantify charisma and good looks and so
that's maybe why you know I have more
assets than then you know use my balance
sheet might predict well this notion is
the same thing but on the company level
maybe if this was if this were Goldman
Sachs's balance sheet maybe it's a book
value per share is six dollars but the
markets willing to pay $12 for it
because it's Goldman Sachs that's the
corporate equivalent of charisma and
good looks they say you know just by
their brand they are able to make more
money than everyone else they're able to
do more with whatever assets we give
them so I'm willing to pay a premium to
their book value and you know whether or
not that's true that's that's a tough
case I think that argument can very
easily be made with a company like
coca-cola where it does have a very
powerful brand where that brand and that
formula that secret formula really are
the value of the firm and they probably
aren't captured on their balance sheet
with a bank I'd be a little more
skeptical of paying a significant
multiple of this right here what
multiple are we paying if this is the
market value so let's say this is the
mark the stock price or the market stock
price market stock price I'd be
skeptical of of paying two times the
book value but it's actually not hard to
find a lot of companies that are trading
at far more than two times the book
value so that's what it means that's
what the market is essentially saying if
they're paying $12 a share for something
that essentially has a book value of $6
per share they're saying well or maybe
one of these assets are worth more maybe
they had you know on the books there's
like a a property here and and I don't
know Manhattan that they bought 50 years
ago that they have it on the books for
50 cents but maybe the shareholders say
oh no that's really worth a million
dollars or something I don't know and
another way to think about it is if the
market is paying twelve million dollars
per share what's the market cap of the
company and the market cap of the
company is really the what's the markets
guess of what the shareholders equity is
so the market cap you take $12 per share
multiply it by 500 million shares so 12
times 500 million or let's say 0.5
billion and you get a six billion dollar
market cap so if the if the equity is
trading or if the stock is trading that
day at $12 per share that says that the
market or at least the people on the
margin trading that stock that day and
I'll do another whole nother set of
videos on what that means and how prices
are set but that means that they think
that this equity isn't 3 billion that
it's actually worth
six billion dollars and I told you for
all the reasons maybe the brand is worth
a lot or they have some secret formula
or one of these assets somehow is
understated so that's fine that's the
situation where the market price is
above the book value but what's the
situation where let's say that on that
day of trading the share price is at
three dollars per share three dollars
per share well if we say three times
point five billion that means that the
market says that this company's market
cap is 1.5 billion or another way of
viewing it is that this is the markets
guess or you could about the market
value of the equity this is the markets
guess of the value of this company's
equity so the market says okay I don't
care that you know Bank a says that they
have three billion dollars that their
assets minus liabilities are three
billion we don't buy it we actually
think that this is only worth 1.5
billion dollars and it's probably
because they think that one of these
things on the left hand side of the
balance sheet one of these assets are
worth less than what the bank says
they're worth I mean it could be that
you know one of these liabilities are
worth more maybe there's some type of
environmental liability that the
companies somehow understating but let's
not get too complicated right now I'll
do a bunch of videos on that but when
the when the market value or the market
cap is below the book value the book
equity that's the market to say hey
we're calling your bluff something here
doesn't smell right something here isn't
worth what you say it's worth and I just
realized that I'm out of time and I will
continue this in the next video